[Musique]
il
au stud bonjour je vous êtes 3 vous êtes
qui vous êtes jonathan may bowles à vous
êtes hugo mendez et vous êtes jonathan
ruraux vous êtes 3 jeune versaillais
vous êtes ici pour nous parler de votre
association qui s'appelle au stud et de
votre motivation dans la vie a souvent
je crois à créer des événements à base
de musique électronique et une de vos
passions
voilà on va essayer de vous découvrir un
peu plus et où surtout pour nous
présenter un événement qui va avoir lieu
le samedi 18 mai à versailles par de la
bonaventure voilà ceci étant dit alors
jonathan may bowles a qui êtes vous
exactement
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans la vie je suis
assistant chef de projet d'accord et
vous hebdomadaire l'immobilier l'auto
très bien immobilier et janna thériault
et moi je serais je suis chef
d'entreprise dans le domaine touristique
très bien donc vous êtes tous les trois
gars ça y est et vous avez monté cette
association au stud quand c'était en
2015 en 2001 2015 voilà vous êtes tous
les trois et quel est votre but donc
plus précisément le but je pense que
c'est ce qui nous a unis
voilà qui s'était en fait pas forcément
comment s'appelle de créer en fait des
événements et dynamiser la ville de
versailles
voilà peut-être partie de ces concepts
s'est dit bon on en a marre d'aller sur
paris versailles et finalement qu'est ce
qui se passe à versailles pour les
jeunes pas grand chose à moi j'ai envie
de faire un tout petit retour en arrière
juste avec jonathan qui est le créateur
de honey friends avec ça antoine bouhey
il ya quelques années qui a fait le même
constat et non concept et qui s'était
dit il se passe rien pourquoi toujours
aller à paris faisant des choses à
versailles pour les jeunes donc c'était
ça vous organiser des soirées on y prête
et ça a super bien marché
ça c'est dit parenthèse refermée
bousculent donc vous allez on a voulu go
dites moi donc vous êtes dit appeler
même chose finalement c'est dur fait un
peu la même chose ils se connaissaient
aussi de de vue peut-être on a commencé
à sortir ensemble nous ça on va passer
ce délai vous avez exactement ça reste
comme ça reste privé et au final qu'est
ce qu'on a fait on a pris un studio de
musique
donc on a lancé notre label de musique
en 2015 déjà vous avez lancé à la belle
a fait on a nancy on appelle ça c'était
le départ ça c'était de départ ouais
c'était là s'appelle alors qu'ils
s'appellent au stud en fait c'est le
même nom mais où est donc après qu'est
ce qui s'est passé on a continué on
avance et on ne fait divers événements
je la main mais non mais dites moi
yakhi d'un ce label différents dj y
appartiennent que artistique artistique
j'ai parlé à peu près six ou sept dj oui
qu'on essaie de faire tourner sur paris
en l'occurrence là ça fait deux ans
qu'on tourne pas mal sur paris c'est à
dire que les fai participent à des
événements exact justement l'idée l'idée
c'était aussi de pouvoir se montrer
aussi à paris soit de monter des
événements toutes pièces en étant
résident des soirées de a à z ou de
démarcher des événements au pouvoir
proposer nos artistes
exactement et puis courant de l'année
on s'est dit pourquoi pas revenir et
recentré après notre notre énergie sur
versailles
justement partant du constat qu'il est à
forcer c'est ça et le et de le mettre et
de le concentrer sur versailles sur une
zone qu'on connaît très bien parce qu'on
n'y a vécu parce qu'on est agrandi mais
je pense que c'est c'est un peu comme ça
que je vous voyais les choses en tout
cas des clans de pouvoir d'innover à
l'échec les spécialités dans
l'association danse vous apparemment
c'est le domaine directeur artistique
m'occupe des programmations
la fibre des événements aussi en
l'occurrence savoir dans quelle
direction veut aller sur un événement
est ce que c'est
vous avez différentes positions d'avant
devait de mauriciens donc
donc voilà et puis et vous allergènes
attend davantage du coup la percée de la
barre si et communication ouais un peu
de logistique et en fait on se rejoint
sur voilà on est oui en fait on fuit
lâchant qu'un autre partie mis en son
centre est tous ça c'est pour le côté
artistique tous les deux de la musique
donc forcément on donne aussi ses
emportements issue en ce moment on
n'achète ya un pôle ne parle pas c'est
vraiment la communication à la je vais
attend seulement la direction artistique
et hugo c'est vraiment la globalité
logistique contusions et une relation
partenariat commercial avec un très bon
commercial et à venir ok génial alors
donc là vous avez déjà participé à pas
mal ou créer pas mal d'événements même à
versailles
je crois que lors de la fête de la
musique dites moi ce que vous avez fait
on devrait alors en deux mots
on a mis en avant pas mal d'artistes
dont nos artistes donc reçu dans votre
écurie et puis le but c'est aussi de
pouvoir si de nouveaux dj de jeunes dj
c'est ça en fait parce que je crois que
vous attirer pas mal des plus jeunes
encore qui sont un petit peu fatiguée
parce que vous faire technique qui
viennent voir la quête qui vous disaient
leur multi veulent participer à leur
manière et mettez vous leur mettez pied
à l'étrier on en salive ce qui est
marrant c'est qu'on a reçues quand je
sais pas si tu verras vécu mais en fait
on a une page facebook
ouais on reçoit des messages avec des
mix et donc ça c'est en nous ça me fait
plaisir parce qu'en fait ils sont
intéressés par le cros bonnes idées dans
l'écurie
aussi voit aussi ses choix peut-être que
vous avez left à répondre à une demande
et vous avez un monde fou où chaque fois
je sais que le premier musée fait un
événement il ya eu presque 500 personnes
à l'hôtel du côté des nouveautés
voilà du son magnifique j'ai eu des
échos nonce et on perd ça c'est une
équipe jeune qui a besoin de
d'événements
tel que celui ci non c'est vrai que
l'ancien république pour samedi sont
contents de rester avec gm finalement
des nôtres à belleville donc le temps
profiter tout ça profite à tort alors on
va un petit peu se centrer sur ce fameux
18 mai donc ça lieu parc de la
bonaventure chf thaïs un bel endroit pas
forcément connus qui est très grand
c'est assez vaste donc il y aura vous il
y aura beau dj c'est ça voilà il y aura
des stands partenaires ou si on fait des
partenariats pour animer un petit peu
l'endroit et la journée c'est toute une
journée c'est dur de keller et leurs
inventeurs de miliana seulement voilà
alors parlez nous des partenariats ben
l'occurrence on va essayer de créer un
petit village avec des partenaires dont
des ateliers on mettra en place des
ateliers aussi bien pour les petits que
pas aussi d'après petit pour tous les
âges voilà ça c'est au coeur des
ateliers comme une nécessité d
initiation au mix donc la protesta la
proche de l'inde d'aciers connaître
pourquoi pas j'espère en tout cas et
donc hier du yoga c'est chez toi y en a
un côté bien-être
enfin ensuite de faire plusieurs
plusieurs poules et c'est quoi votre
type comme par les traders dans une
optique à chaque éveil alors l'idée
c'est que
si c'est quoi la ligne la ligne
wen a une on est en plein air il va
faire beau
l'openair exactement 1 on l'a pas dit
voilà c'est un beau j'espère on espère
tous parce que de toute façon on aura
passé à annuler ou pas c'est votre art
exporter ce sera pas annulée on prend à
une initiative qui fera qu' on refera
l'événement mais peut-être un peu plus
tard d'accord à la grèce allait donc
donc la ligne la ligne
on est dans la verdure on est dans un
parc qui fait beau on va essayer de
trouver des choses et des ateliers qui
correspondent un peu au fait d'être dans
la nature quelque part donc un esprit un
peu zen
on va avoir un street food qui va venir
par exemple poussé un petit petit stand
de glaces qui propose de voter alors bio
en tout cas de qualité mais en tout cas
d'une localité du coin parce que les
dollars l'idée car il fait ici
il a une petit reste ans ces personnes
qui venaient le but c'est pas ce soir à
dire ce que de la musique tu de la fête
et c'est aussi le but c'est aussi de
présenter de proposer aussi des
activités à côté pour les petits et plus
grande actuellement encore exactement
combien tu es vraiment moi si je peux me
permettre la ligne j'ai l'impression que
c'est un petit peu l'écologie gérable ce
que commença au gros coup de tête
d'enfant ça s'appelle la tête dans les
nuages se trouve là et ils seront bien
sûr voilà c'est ce qu'ont parce que
c'est un nous partenaires sondés comme
des poufs géant destiné à être dehors
exactement fin mais voilà si elles sont
recyclées en toile de montgolfières
voilà donc ça faisait la lumière c'est
un bon concept et il ya tout ce qui
gravite autour il fait travailler des
personnes sur saint denis pour la
réinsertion sociale dont qui attire tout
un concept autour de ça et c'est
plaisant de travailler avec eux
ce genre d'entreprise la soirée donc le
yoga c'est le bien-être des radios train
il ya d'ailleurs des jeux en bois pour
les enfants des bons jeux
des jeux géants en bois si on fait venir
l'université de saint quentin une
association qui s'appelle canada's qui
s'appelle pégase exactement il fat ils
vont faire une offre un atelier chimie
de chimie pour les enfants en mêlant
drame a expliqué brièvement là j'avoue
que je suis pas encore tout le monde
peut dire qu il ya des choses
différentes et qui je pense enfin j'en
suis certain mon coeur voilà fond plat
bien sûr y'a pas de raison c'est top
donc de la chimie de la musique donc les
gens dansent tu peux soir s'allongent
sur profiter du soleil vous êtes se
faire maquiller les chiffres censés
faire maquiller on va faire une espèce
de stand de maquillage pour les savait
pas mal donc génial merci d'apporter
tous à notre bonne ville de versailles
puis j'espère que moi c'est sûr vous
allez avoir un monde fou parce que vos
événements marche du feu de dieu à
chaque fois et plaisent énormément moi
j'ai beaucoup d'échos dans tous mes amis
jeunes
dernier point mais bien sûr
programmation qu'on a fait pour le 18
justement on a fait venir des artistes
qui vont jouer en live avec des machines
à analogie à temps ce sera pas que dj et
non sur un aspect qui sera différent de
ce qu'on a pu voir le premier donc
où il ya que dj alors à faire vraiment
quelque chose qui sera tourné vers le
live
on a deux artistes les groove boys
toujours prêt ils vont jouer en vrai
avec des machines analogiques des
claviers synthétiseurs ça vous paraît
web un égout on va dire que si vous avez
synthétiseur way synthétiseurs des
boîtes à rythmes et donc ils vont jouer
en live c'est génial
concert électro irak ira à eux et
d'autres il y aura en tout cas en live
ce sera à eux principalement à keller
vous leur exacte jeunes départ en tête
ça parce qu'on n'a pas sorti encore la
programmation avec les heures il faut
venir en terre de toute façon d'étouffer
toute façon très bonne de 12h à 20h
certains morts voilà ce sans tomber
coûté on y sera samedi de jumet jeu pas
de la bonaventure versailles jonathan
jonathan hugo
merci beaucoup mais très vite pour
d'autres événements top ça va merci
[Musique]